my name is John Fults and I am the
director of user interface technology at
Wolfram research which basically means I
spend a lot of time thinking about our
notebook for an end and I'm gonna be
talking about effectively using
notebooks in 11.3 and my talk is
actually going to cover notebooks even
at a more basic level there will be a
mixture of just an introduction to
notebooks generally and and covering
some features which are new to 11:3 if
you don't have a lot of experience using
our products I think this will be a nice
gentle introduction for you if you're a
longtime user of our products some of
the things I'm saying will sound
familiar but some of the things will
definitely be new so let's go ahead and
get started ok and just briefly I'm not
really sticking to this outline very
rigidly but generally this the kinds of
things I want to cover I want to define
what a notebook is and I want to give
some patterns for notebook usage and a
few tips for power a notebook usage so
what is a notebook a notebook is a
structured document and when I say
structured specifically it's broken up
into units called cells and cells are
typically denoted by what we refer to as
cell brackets that live on the right
hand side of the screen and I'm hoping
that you can see my cursor here and I'm
pointing here to sell to the cell
brackets for these particular cells and
I'm highlighting them so a cell can
contain narrative text and this is an
example of that a cell can contain code
and so this is an example of some code
written in the Wolfram language which
you can probably figure out pretty
quickly what it's going to do here a
cell might contain images as well and
here's just a bit of code which produces
an image you can get images into the
product by other means copy and paste
and such as well but this is an example
produce my code and a cell can also
contain math and here we have a simple
quadratic formula and you can see I've
actually put a little bit of typesetting
in here typeset math and more
typesetting comes back when I evaluates
the structure of a notebook is
hierarchical so what I mean by that is
that the cells coalesce into cell groups
and these cell groups are generally
determined by specific cell styles so in
my set of examples here below the fold I
have a subsection cell and I have a sub
subsection cell the sub sub section cell
is grouped by the sub section cell and
you can see there is a grouping bracket
out here that contains both of them
actually that contains everything here
and then the sub sub section cell groups
the things below it and you can see in
an inner grouping brackets and here is
another example of a code cell and we
refer to these oftentimes as input cells
and output cells and input cells group
output cells and so you can see it
created a brand new group when I perform
the evaluation by pressing shift enter I
like on my keyboard so cell grouping can
be performed manually as well if for
some reason you don't care for the the
particular way that things have been
grouped I'll just override the group in
here by going into the cell menu and
using group cells together and you'll
see it changes to cell grouping entirely
and now I'm gonna go ahead and undo that
just by pressing command Z or control Z
on my keyboard to undo that and I also
want to demonstrate that cells can
collapse so this is convenient if you
want to take advantage of the structure
to temporarily or even permanently hide
contents and so free and generally you
do this by double clicking on the cell
or a grouping bracket that you want to
collapse so I'm double clicking on the
top cell here and it collapses
everything and when it collapses you
will see that the grouping bracket the
outer grouping bracket still exists with
a little down arrow there we also have
and this is new to 11 3 we also have for
some cells we have a more visible notion
that you're working with a cell with a
closed cell group which is this opener
right here and you can see when I mouse
over it it highlights and I can open the
cell group by clicking this as well and
similarly for the subsection cells I
should also point out that in some cases
you don't always necessarily want to
collapse on the topmost thing for these
you know for these sections that
subsection cell you generally do but in
the case of input and outputs well you
might want to collapse on input but you
might also want to collapse on output
oftentimes the output is more
interesting than the input and if you
want to collapse on the output you can
do that by simply double-clicking the
output cell and this is what we call a
reverse closed cell group and you'll
notice that the cell grouping bracket is
here with a tiny little arrow that's
pointing upward to indicate that this
group is reverse closed a notebook and
you may wonder where I'm getting all of
these styles and colors from a notebook
styles are defined in a style sheet and
this is true for all notebooks so styles
are displayed in the format Styles menu
so here I just have a gender
so and I will open the format menu and
the style menu you can see right now
this cell is displayed in the text style
I have the check mark next to the text
style and I can change it to be
something else like for example a
section so all of the most common Styles
can be accessed by keyboard shortcuts
and they tend to be the same regardless
of which style sheet you use and there
are many style sheets
I will not actually demonstrate the
style sheets because that would mess up
my slideshow a bit but let's show so
here you can see that there are various
various styles which are bound to
command one through command nine this is
on my Macintosh on a Windows machine or
a Linux machine they're bound to alt one
through all nine and most of these
styles tend to they may be visually
distinct but they tend to have the same
names and the same functionality from
from one style sheet to the next you can
also make your own styles and let me
demonstrate making your own style just
by doing format edit style sheet now in
this case I have a notebook that already
has a private style sheet if you would
do this on a brand new notebook it
wouldn't have all of the interesting
extra styles here but let's just go
ahead and define our own style so I'm
going to define a style called my style
I'll just press enter and here we go
it's added my style to the bottom and
let's do something to my style to make
it visually distinct so we'll look under
the format menu and let's set its text
color to green and let's set its
background color to say light orange
just to make it especially garish and
let's set its font size to be fairly
large
and we could of course have done any
number of other things too
and not even just font attributes we
might for example change the alignment
so that it's centers when we're finished
with this we can just go ahead and close
it I think I'll be lost if we close it
we can always get it back by hitting
edit style sheet again and now I still
have this cell selected and now we will
see in the style menu my style has shown
up and there we go with our garish color
choices notebooks can help you track the
history of computation so in and out
numbers track evaluations in the current
session and we've already seen examples
this I didn't specifically call them out
but here we have this is showing the
input is the 8th input that I have
evaluated in this session and this is
the output corresponding to that input
with the same number now if I quit and
because this is this notebook front-end
is hooked up to a kernel I can quit the
kernel without quitting the notebook
front-end if I quit then these numbers
won't be of active in a current session
anymore and new to 11 3 we signify this
by changing the labeling and you can see
the in and out labels continue to be
present but they are now have their
numbers obscured if we really wanted to
know what number they'd been assigned in
a past session we get a tooltip it says
it was in 8 in a previous session but
the fact that it was an 8th input in a
kernel session which is no longer alive
is not that interesting to us anymore
so let's go ahead and start a kernel
again and now we're back to in 1 and out
1 because we started our fresh kernel
and now I'd like to demonstrate one of
the other things that we do with
inputs and outputs and that is
indicating whether or not an input and
an output or match to one another so
I've just evaluated this so obviously
this output matches this input but I
might choose to make some changes
say for example I want to change my
cosine function to be a tangent function
and here it looks like this has been
disabled I did not try this in my
slideshow environments there we go so
this is what you would normally see here
the the dimming effect simply means that
the output doesn't match the input if I
were to go back and retype cosine again
then the dimming goes away but I type
tan and now I know that these inputs are
not matched but I do a shift in our
evaluation it creates a new plot and
they are now matched again and this is
pretty it's pretty good about figuring
out what matches and what doesn't for
example if I were to just add a comment
here and the comment of course makes no
difference to the way in which the
evaluation performs it figures out that
the comment makes no difference and it
returns it back to a match States
the notebook environment supports a rich
Wolfram language authoring experience as
you might expect of course and let me
just talk a little bit about that
experience there are a number of things
that I certainly do when I'm working
directly with notebooks which which I
hope that many people have figured out
but in case they don't let's go through
them so for example one of the things
that I like to do when I'm dealing with
the structure of Wolfram language is to
use triple clicking so just like in any
document editing application a single
click establishes a text editing caret
there and a double click will select a
word but a triple click understands the
structure of your program and in this
case it's actually selected not just the
geometric transformation that I'd triple
clicked on but it selects the entire
geometric transformation expression and
this isn't just about the fact that it
since L brackets either so in this case
if I triple click plot label it
understands that the immediate structure
surrounding the plot label was a rule
plot label is used as an option and it
selected the entire option if I triple
click on an opening curly brace then it
selects the entire list not just the
opening curly brace also the closing
curly brace if I triple click and drag
so I'm now holding the button down on
the 3rd click now it continues to select
structure so everything that I just did
was using the mouse I can also use the
keyboard some of you may be really
interested in keyboard navigation and
which people would pay more attention to
it I'm keenly interested in keyboard
navigation myself so in this case I am
pressing ctrl period
and this keyboard shortcut works on all
platforms I pressed it once and it
started from where my insertion point
was there inside geometric
transformation and it went up one level
in structure if I press it again it will
go up another level in structure
selecting the entire geometric
transformation if I press it again it
will go up another level in structure
and so on and in fact you might think
that it would stop here but I can even
press one more time even though I have
the entire content selected what is the
next level and structure that it might
go up it might select the entire cell
bracket and indeed that's what happens
so in addition to that I wanted to just
briefly demonstrate the experience of
editing code so the code editor provides
completions and templates and other
Wolfram language facilities so when you
type we have a curated set of
completions and I can just press tab
right here and accept that completion
and then I'm going to do something
different here in this case I'll go
ahead and press tab or I could have
completed typing it and now notice that
there is a little thing that sticks out
here with with an eye and that will take
you to the help page I'm not going to
demonstrate that but I will demonstrate
this other side which is the down arrow
and since I'm a keyboard guy I'm going
to actually access this just by pressing
the down arrow and now we see a list of
possible templates for my plotting
function and I can choose whichever one
I like I'm just going to go ahead and
choose the first one and now that's
pasted in and if I start typing here
then I can do that for example and now I
can press the tab key and it will go to
the
next spot and the next spots and the
next box notebooks support rich data
embedding and this is something that has
gotten even better in 11.3 the so first
of all starting with something which is
perfectly possible before I'm just going
to bring in something from from our
homepage here now of course I could
refer to this imports repeatedly
whenever I wanted to refer to this image
but maybe I want to embed the image in
the notebook so that I don't have to be
on a network connection to access the
image or maybe I want to give it to
other people who may not have access to
the image for some reason it might be a
file on my system so what I can do is I
can just click next to the image and I
can begin typing and here I'm actually
writing a program with an inline image
now at the image change size that was
just for the convenience of being able
to type around it the image is not
fundamentally any different when I do an
evaluation it's going to work exactly as
it would on the original image so that's
something that we were able to do before
here's something that's new so we have
this facility called ICANN eyes we're
gonna go ahead and evaluate this right
now because this takes just a little bit
to evaluate what I can eyes allows us to
do is it allows us to take what may be a
large and messy thing that lives in the
kernel and embed it in your notebook so
in this case well I might have a problem
here partly because this did take a long
time to evaluate partly because github
has some limitations where if you hit
them too hard too many times from a
given machine then they may block you
out for an hour
or something like that I don't want that
to happen so what I've done is I've
created an ionized blob for lack of a
better word here that represents the
entire data and so now I can actually
begin just doing just treating it as if
it were the in place data and so I'm
just going to assign it to a variable
show some outputs now the important part
of this to understand is that this data
actually lives in the notebook so I
could delete this cell entirely and
leave only this cell and then give it to
someone else and they'll be able to work
with the same data set that I'm using
here so in this case I've made an
ionized blob by using the icon eyes
command you can also make an ionized
blob let me collapse this you can also
make an ionized blob interactively and
so I'm just going to take let's say the
first 25 elements of that data and here
well it's kind of messy maybe I want to
embed this as an example but I don't
want to look at this this is kind of
silly I maybe I want to get the flavor
of it but I want to look at it well
let's use our triple click drag trick
which we learned and I'm going to triple
click drag oh let's say just everything
is set the first now in the last element
now I'm going to right click and I'm
going to choose I can eyes and now this
is an equivalent expression if we
evaluate it it will be exactly the same
but we've hidden 23 items in this list
and in this case I used it to represent
data but it doesn't have to be data I
could have used the
to represent code as well notebooks are
fully computable entities this is
something I always like to emphasize so
notebook elements are discoverable
objects which can be manipulated and I
won't be able to go very far in the time
and I have allotted but here's just a
couple of brief examples so in this case
I am assigning to the variable C an
object which represents this cell right
here and now I can operate on a cell and
what I'm going to do for this input is
I'm going to say take that cell and set
its background to be like blue and I can
operate in more significant ways on the
notebook in this case I'm going to use
notebook imports to do a sort of data
scraping operation on my notebook all of
these bulleted list items these use the
item style and so basically what I am
doing here is I'm taking all the cells
in the item style and returning them as
a list of strings so I'm going to
evaluate that and then you can see in my
result all of the bulleted points that
I've gone through and all the ones I've
yet to go through now it turns out that
all of the data in a notebook can be
represented as a Wolfram language
expression so here's an example where
I'm taking that C variable representing
the cell here and I'm just going to read
it directly and here we go and we can
see this is what the underlying
expression looks like and so I'm going
to make change to it I'm just going to
use standard Wolfram language operation
is to change it and this works very well
so in this case I'm just going to say
look for any case where it references
the variable C and let's replace it with
the variable the cell and then we're
just going to write the resulting so
Express
and back into our notebook and there we
go
an identical cell but except for having
replaced C with the cell what we've
covered so far is using notebooks
primarily as documents and we've seen
some examples of some embedded
interfaces but I wanted to make sure
that that was one of the things that's
that's very cool about notebooks is
documents is you can have live
interfaces with them and here in one
line of code with an embedded graphic so
that we can very easily see what's going
on here I've just created an interface
which simply calls color quantize with a
variable number of colors which is tied
to a slider and then it's going to show
the quantized version and it's going to
show the the histogram of the results
and let me and if I drag this across you
can see it more colors pop in and the
histogram then gets more complex as I
move to the right and this is something
that works in real time notebooks can be
used for other sorts of documents as
well the help system actually is fully
composed of notebooks and so if I open
the help system and let's go to a page
maybe the page for module for example
and this is a notebook just like any
other it has evaluatable cells and i can
run through and evaluate these things
myself and and I can make changes to
them if I want and everything just works
notebooks can also be dialog boxes and
palettes if you've used their product
before you've probably seen that we have
a number of interesting palettes here
and so for example here
the basic math assistant which you can
use to paste in various sorts of
typesetting what you may not be aware is
that many of our dialog boxes are also
notebooks and so for example the fine
dialog box is a notebook well it doesn't
look very impressive but because it's a
notebook I can I can type in typeset
expressions and then let's go searching
for a superscript x squared in our
documents and sure enough there we've
found it